John woods is general manager of
coca-cola Britain and joins me now so
John in the UK there's 36 million
plastic bottles bought every every year
every day only half of them are recycled
I mean do you feel a moral obligation to
address that well I want to get them all
back so I want all of our plastic
packaging back because I don't want to
see it lying at the side of the road or
the peaches Beach any more than anybody
else I think there's three things that
we can do to actually encourage more
recycling and get more of the plastic
back the first is we've announced though
that we're going to double the amount of
recycled PT that we use in all of our
plastic bottles going from 25% today to
50% in the future that creates a market
for recycled plastic and creates an
economic environment in which those
recyclers can prosper and create and gen
and deliver the products which we need
for our bottles that's the first thing
Greenpeace say you're already targeting
40% is 50% that much of an ink well it's
a stretch because actually the maximum
we could get to just over 50% because
today as you said only 50% of bottles
are actually recycled just over 50 57
percent to be precise are actually
recycled so we're going to get above 50
which is a huge step forward in fact
we're already doing more than anybody
else in our industry to use to recycle
plastic but we're going to double down
on that and double to 50 the second
thing we're doing is we're going to
launch a new marketing campaign because
sometimes consumers just need to be
reminded to recycle so we're going to
launch a new coca-cola marketing
campaign called love story it features
two plastic bottles who fall in love and
are recycled to meet each other again
and again and again and we could try and
use the brand to connect with consumers
and encourage them to recycle more and
the third thing is we're calling for a
reform of the existing recovery schemes
because they're not working as well as
they should be we get 57% of our plastic
bottles back actually the best in class
around the world is above 90% so we can
we know as the country and as an
industry we can do a lot better why not
move to glass bottles and have deposit
scheme well we do have some glass
bottles already plastic packaging is
actually very lightweight efficient and
safe convenient packaging to use we use
some glass bottles particularly in the
in pubs and clubs and deposit return
schemes which
been talked about for some time I say
I'm entirely open to deposit returns
scheme if it's well managed and it's
sufficiently run because I mean your
parent company's pretty much against
deposit return schemes around the world
why have you been able to persuade them
that Britain's a different case well
actually we use deposit return schemes
in multiple countries around the world
several European markets like Germany
some states of the US they exist around
the world and coca-cola is part of those
schemes but shouldn't glass I mean on
the basis of the plastic bottle can take
450 years to break down I mean shouldn't
we just be using glass anyway because
it's so much more easily recycled well
but actually the carbon footprint of
using glass is significantly higher it's
heavier material to use it cost more to
transport etc so actually the carbon
footprint is quite high the only time
plastic becomes a problem is if it's not
recycled if it's thrown away so I think
the best way forward for us is actually
to drive up the recycling rates that's
why I'm targeting 50 percent recycle
plastic in all of our plastic bottles
and also using the marketing skills that
we have that we have as a company to
encourage more consumers to recycle
alright your mushroom coca-cola GB
thanks very much you don't come back and
tell us how you get on when it's well
then you take the target thank you